did you know that the blue tassels that
are hanging out from the sites of
buggies hat are actually his hair tied
together into ponytails there you go
even if you decide to stop watching this
video right now I hope that this at
least blew your mind a little I've
talked a lot about one piece and have
analyzed a lot of characters but one
thing that I never would have guessed
would be so interesting to discuss
within the series in particular is buggy
when you guys rose to my challenge last
week and chosen for the next video I
didn't expect buggy to be able to teach
us as much about one piece as it turns
out that he actually does not only is
buggy a perfect representation of the
story of one piece itself but he also
teaches us a lot about what the actual
one piece might be and speaking of the
challenge you guys did an amazing job
what better time to take a closer look
at the warlords then right now where
they might become super relevant to the
story again
also since last week's challenge was a
crushing defeat for me since you managed
to get 2,000 likes in just seven hours I
think we have to raise the bar a little
for the next one and see if you can
still make it so if you manage to bring
this video to three thousand likes in
the very first 24 hours the next video
will be out by next Tuesday but now grab
yourself a big cup of your favorite hot
or cold beverage of choice we have to
talk about buggy buggy the clown has
earned his epithet for a reason his
character design is centered around the
varying theme of a circus clown mixed
with that of a pirate most of the time
we can see buggy wearing makeup as well
as his quite cloudy white gloves and
pointy shoes the rest of his outfit is
that of a pirate Admiral with a big
marine like coat and a big pirate hats
now if you ask yourself why anyone would
freely choose to dress in that way the
answer to that is buggies most prominent
cloud feature his big red nose because
his nose is not just another part of his
costume but his real actual nose it
doesn't come as a big surprise then that
buggy has always been very sensitive
about this
and most likely it's the main reason for
his insecurity that is a big driver of
his character this goes so far that
buggy at one point Ethan destroys an
entire town when kids are making fun of
his nose but he has made the most of his
unique looks and embraced the at first a
little quirky looking clown theme
however if we're completely honest I
think we can all admit that buggies
design is actually pretty cool and if
one piece teaches us one thing in
particular
it's that whether someone looks bad as a
weird is mostly determined by the
character's personality and strength
while he was actually introduced as a
quite shallow villain very early on in
the story by Oda his popularity with the
fans and Oda himself led to buggy slowly
but steadily getting a more and more
refined character builds so much so that
his backstory is as far from shallow as
it gets born somewhere on the ground
line buggy served as an apprentice on
the ship of the pirate king himself
while it at first appears as if he
didn't enjoy his time there at all we
slowly but steadily learn that he had a
much closer relationship to his crew
than we all initially thought for
example we now know that during his time
on the aura Jackson he highly respects
and admires Rayleigh and Odin and just
like shanks buggy must have had a very
close relationship with Roger since we
can see him crying at his captain's
execution and speaking of shanks while
at first it seemed like buggy detested
his fellow apprentice it more and more
looks like they actually also had a
quite close relationship not only do the
Marines describe the relationship as a
brotherly bond but even white beard
states that he remembers the two always
being together seeing the two arm and
arm on board of the ro Jackson really
rounds this impression off for me and as
we know shanks even invited buggy to
join him after Rogers death buggy
however decides to leave the world of
the yonkos and pirate Kings behind and
tries to make a name for himself outside
of the new world
so despite is quite exciting and
unexpected backstory we first meet buggy
in the East blue in orange town as one
of the first major antagonist
of the crew but what really is it about
the clown that makes him into such a fan
favorites while the initial impression
with buggy is often that he's a weak and
incapable pirate that is actually not
the case
on the contrary Bucky is quite smart he
has an eye for opportunities and
understands to influence and deceive
those around him a great example for
this is Bucky recruiting dozens of
strong prisoners from imple down into
his crew and joining the ranks of the
Shikibu Kai all after having to join
Luffy on his way into the depths of the
prison and onto the battlefield at
marine forts plus we know that he's also
a very capable chemist developing his
own variety of weapons like the buggy
bolts and while buggy certainly is not
comparable to other members of the Raja
pirates in terms of fighting strength
he's by no means weak having fought
alongside and against many legendary
pirates even if a bit reluctantly surely
has left its mark on him also buggy
wields a quite formidable devil fruit
power that not only allows him to float
but also avoid the tax of the likes of
sorrow and mihawk a defining trait of
buggy that he partly shares with Luffy
is also his dumb luck no matter how dire
the situation looks buggy always manages
to pull his head out of the sling
somehow no matter if it's escaping
smoker instructive lightning clean
slashed by mihawk or even being frozen
by okichi but he somehow always makes it
out of these situations alive and
sometimes even for the better the truly
charming part about his personality
however is the weird mix between comic
relief and serious character that he
brings to the story because his purpose
in the story seems to alternate between
simply making the reader laugh or
actually impacting the plot in
meaningful ways on the one hand buggy is
often very hysterical and tends to cause
a lot of confusion by misunderstanding
or miscommunicating when talking to
others on the other hand however we also
know of buddy's insecurities and how he
has to overcome them in order to become
a better person
slowly he has become more and
relevant to the actual plot of the story
so in the end this weird mix has led to
buggy getting a quite significant amount
of character development over the course
of the story despite his initial design
in a way I think he could even argue
that it's the same recipe that oda has
used with shanks a character that was
introduced as a simple and comic
character at the beginning of the story
that slowly turned out to be more and
more of a big deal a really big piece of
evidence that buggy is an important
character to oda is that he has a dream
buggy also wants to become the Pirate
King and once again oda takes a twist on
that dream with his character while
falou fee the Pirate King is the person
with the most freedom and for Blackbeard
the one with the most power for buggy
being The Pirate King means being the
person with the most fortune in the
world he much rather thinks of treasure
in terms of gold and silver but
nonetheless he also has a dream that he
strives to fulfill so if you ever
wondered why buggy is such a popular
character it's because he has gained a
lot more depth over the course of the
story than we all could have anticipated
when we first get to meet him now what
does all of this have to do with one
piece and more importantly with the one
piece well this is where we have to look
at buggies character arc
you see buggies arc over the course of
the story can be summarized as a sort of
personification of the story when we
meet him in the east blue and orange
town he's the first major antagonist to
luffy's our enemy he starts out as a
quite stereotypical
suitable and purely comic villain that
our heroes have to take down but then
just like the story itself buggy starts
to become a bit more serious
he gets new new layers of background and
personality and bit by bits he turns
more and more complex and slowly even
starts to get a political gravity when
becoming a warlord I think you agree
with me when I say that this is exactly
what happened to the story of one piece
as a whole starting off as a pure
adventure in a world of tropical islands
and treasures as well as a friends and
villains one piece soon got a more heavy
tone and Oda gave his story more and
more depth character and complexity both
Bucky and the story are heavily
influenced by the main character monkey
Dee Luffy and for both marine Ford was a
central turning point for the readers
perception of them during the orange
town arc but he turns a little bit
kinder after being defeated by Luffy
but the paramount war is the art buggy
truly changed the most as a character
not only does he end up helping within
multiple times even if it initially is
out of self-interest but he also grows
as a pirate rising into the ranks of the
Warlord's buggy went from a completely
comedic character to a tactician that
has United countless strong pirates
under his banner and even people like
mr. three who are aware of the facade
he's putting on still decide to stick
with him do you see how drastically
different that is from early buggy he
truly embodies the development of one
piece but we're not done yet because
buggy not only teaches us a lot about
the story of one piece but also about
the one piece itself the treasure left
by gol D Roger and the reason for the
great pirate era you see despite serving
under Roger himself and wanted to become
the Pirate King buggy has no interest
whatsoever in finding laughs tail and
wampie
why is that I think what this clearly
tells us is that buggy has at least a
good idea what the one piece is all
about and even though there's nothing he
loves more than finding treasure he
doesn't want anything to do with it
I think the clear explanation for that
is that the one piece at its core has
nothing to do with gold or silver is it
possible that there are some piles of
jewelry hoarded on laughs tale sure but
bogey seems to know that the true value
of the one piece lies with something
else something that carries such heavy
implication and consequences that any
sort of material a dance would kind of
lose their meaning as whitebeard stated
finding the one piece will shake the
world to its core and while buggy truly
has developed as a character I think
taking on the consequences of
discovering Rajas treasure is something
that only very few people could do after
all buggy shows us really well what
treasure means to different people he
even talks about this with shanks on
board of the hora Jackson for buggy it
means gold and silver but for shanks it
means something more than that
similar like to Roger the one piece will
be something with a unique meaning just
for him and like his jaw head has a
special meaning to Luffy so there you
have it
buggy actually teaches us a lot about
one piece and I think the way things are
going at the moment we can say for
certain that he will become relevant to
the story again soon I hope you guys
enjoyed this video make sure to smash
that like button for a fresh video next
week and subscribe if you aren't already
part of the crew also let me know your
title for buggy that's better than the
clown and I'll present the best one or
two ideas in the next video if you want
to learn more about the characters in
one piece you can simply click here to
keep watching in whatever comfortable
position you're in right now otherwise I
see you around next time and until then
have a wonderful week
you